COMMITTEE HEARING FOR THURSDAY
APRIL TWENTY NINTH TWENTY
TWENTY ONE TO ORDER- OUR VICE
CHAIR AND- A COUPLE OF THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS ARE IN OTHER
COMMITTEES RIGHT NOW BT
THEY'LL BE- THEY'LL BE JOINING
US LATER- WE HAVE TWELVE BILLS
ON THE AGENDA. OF WHICH NINE
ARE RECOMMENDED AS CONSENT
ITEMS ALL OF THESE BILLS ARE
RECOMMENDED FOR APPROVAL. DUE
TO COVERT NINETEEN WE HAVE
LIMITED ROOM AVAILABLE FOR THE
PUBLIC IN THIS ROOM. ROOM ONE
TWENTY FIVE HERE IN THE STATE
CAPITAL IS THE WITNESS VIDEO
CONFERENCING ROOM FOR TODAY'S
HEARING. PLEASE BE MINDFUL OF
THE MAST REQUIREMENT FOR
EVERYONE IN THIS ROOM AND IN
ROOM ONE TWENTY FIVE AND PLEASE
REMEMBER TO MAINTAIN PHYSICAL
DISTANCING. MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC CAN PARTICIPATE IN
TODAY'S HEARING BY CALLING
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE TWO.
EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN. THE
PASSCODE. TWO FOUR TWO SIX TWO
THREE SEVEN. OR THE PUBLIC MAY
VISIT OUR COMMITTEES WEBSITE AT
A. I. N. S. DOT ASSEMBLY DOT CA
DOT G. O. V. NOW LET'S
ESTABLISH A QUORUM OF FOR
COMMITTEE SECRETARY WHO IS- NEW
TO OUR COMMUNITY AND WE WELCOME
TIFFANY. AS OUR SECRETARY I
APOLOGIZE I DON'T KNOW YOUR
LAST NAME TIFFANY. TIFFANY
MORRISON IS OUR COMMITTEE
SECRETARY I DIDN'T DO QUITE ALL
THE HOMEWORK I WAS SUPPOSED TO
DO SO I APOLOGIZE TO YOU
TIFFANY BUT WE WELCOME TIFFANY
AND PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. DALY
DALY HERE MAY PRESENT YUP.
BERMAN BIGELOW BIGELOW HERE
CHEN CHEN HERE COOLEY COOLEY
HERE COOPER COOPER HERE FRAZIER
FRAZIER HERE GIPSON GIPSON HERE
GRAYSON. GRAYSON HERE RODRIGUEZ
RODRIGUEZ HERE VOEPEL. THE BILL
HERE WOOD. WE HAVE A QUORUM. WE
HAVE A QUORUM- WE HAVE NINE
ITEMS ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
THERE'S A MOTION AND SECOND DO
I NEED TO READ ALL THESE ITEMS.
NO GOOD GOOD- THOSE NINE ITEMS
WE ARE ABOUT TO VOTE ON ANY
QUESTIONS BY COMMITTEE MEMBERS
IF NOT LET'S ROLL CALL VOTE
PLEASE. CONSENT CALENDAR DALY
OUR DAILY AYE MAYES BERMAN.
BIGELOW BIGELOW AYE CHAN CHEN
AYE COOLEY COOLEY AYE COOPER
COOPER AYE FRAZIER. GIPSON
GIPSON I GRAYSON GRAYSON AYE
RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ AYE VOEPEL
VOEPEL I WOULD. WHAT'S THE VOTE
COUNT PLEASE. NINE ZERO NINE
ZERO BEAUTIFUL THANK YOU. MR
FRAZIER WANTS TO VOTE AS WELL
CONSENT CALENDAR FRAZIER
FRAZIER AYE GOOD THAT BRING US
TO TEN. GOOD BEAUTIFUL- THE
NEXT ITEM IS ITEM TWO AB THREE
THREE FOUR BY MR MULLIN PLEASE
GO AHEAD SIR. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS PRESENTING AB
THREE THREE FOUR AS SOMEONE
WHO'S HAD MELANOMA I KNOW HOW
SCARY THAT DIAGNOSIS CAN BE.
THIS IMPORTANT ISSUE HITS HOME
FOR ME AB THREE THIRTY FOUR
WILL ESTABLISH A REBUTTABLE
PRESUMPTION AS SKIN CANCER
DEVELOP I CALIFORNIA'S WILDLIFE
OFFICERS AND PARK RANGERS IS
ASSOCIATED WITH EXCESSIVE
EXPOSURE TO THE SUN DURING
THEIR EMPLOYMENT. IT WOULD
REMOVE UNNECESSARY BARRIERS FOR
CALIFORNIA'S WILDLIFE OFFICERS
A PARK RANGERS TO QUALIFY FOR
WORKERS COMPENSATION BENEFITS
ASSOCIATED WITH SKIN CANCER IT
WOULD REDUCE THE DEPARTMENTS OF
FISH AND WILDLIFE AS WELL AS
PARKS AND RECREATION'S EFFORTS
TO INITIATE AND COMPLETE A
WORKERS COMPENSATION.
INVESTIGATION ON ITS CLAIMS.
DOUG HAWKINS RETIRED FISH AND
WILDLIFE ASSISTANT CHIEF WHO
HAS HAD TO HAVE THREE SKIN
CANCER SURGERIES EXPLAINS THE
NECESSITY OF THIS BILL WELL. HE
WRITES SKIN CANCER WAS ALWAYS A
CONCERN TO ME BOTH DURING AND
AFTER MY THIRTY TWO YEARS AS A
WARDEN ESPECIALLY HAVING SPENT
COUNTLESS HOURS DAYS AND WEEKS
AT SEA ON PATROL. I REGULARLY
APPLIED SUNBLOCK AT THE SHEER
AMOUNT OF TIME SPENT IN THE SUN
JUST SEEMS TO OVERWHELM EFFORTS
TO KEEP SKIN CANCER AT BAY. AS
YOU KNOW WARDEN'S HIKE SWEAT
AND OPERATE A VERY DIRTY
ENVIRONMENTS FOR ENDLESS HOURS
AS A RESULT BOTH SKIN BLOCK
CREAM SEEM TO HAVE LITTLE
CHANCE OF REMAINING IN PLACE
THROUGHOUT A PATROL. I KNOW HOW
IMPORTANT GOOD DATA IS ANYTIME
A REBUTTABLE PRESUMPTION IS
BEING DISCUSSED LAST FEBRUARY I
REQUESTED A COMMISSION ON
HEALTH AND SAFETY AND WORKERS
COMPENSATION CHISWICK STUDY ON
THE PREVALENCE OF WORKERS
COMPENSATION CLAIMS FOR SKIN
CANCER FOR WILDLIFE OFFICERS A
PARK RANGERS. AND WHAT THE
PERCENTAGE OF ACCEPTED CLAIMS
VERSUS DENIED CLAIMS WERE AND
HOW EXCESSIVE SUN EXPOSURE MAY
INCREASE THE INCIDENCE OF SKIN
CANCER AMONG THESE PARTICULAR
WORKERS. UNFORTUNATELY WE ALL
KNOW HOW LAST YEAR TURNED OUT
AND SO THE STUDY HAS BEEN
DELAYED BUT NOT FORGOTTEN MY
OFFICE HAS SPOKEN TO THE
DIRECTOR CHISWICK SEVERAL TIMES
AND HE'S ASSURED US THAT THE
STUDY IS A PRIORITY FOR THEM.
AND THAT THEY ARE DOING THEIR
BEST TO COMPLETE IT IN DUE
TIME. SO I AM COMMITTING MISTER
CHAIR SHOULD THIS BILL MOVE
FORWARD TODAY BUT I WILL NOT
MOVE IT OUT OF THE SENATE
WITHOUT THAT STUDY. IN HAND I
TO WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
ARE ONLY MOVING FORWARD WITH A
BILL THAT THE SCIENCE BACKS UP
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
ASKING FOR AN AYE VOTE AND I
HAVE. A FEW WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT. MISTER MULLIN FAN YOU
FOR THAT COMMITMENT THAT YOU
JUST HIGHLIGHTED OF. ABOUT
WAITING FOR THE RESULTS OF THE
STUDY AND- WE WANT TO HELP YOU
WERE WITH THAT ENTIRE PROCESS
OF I UNDERSTAND YOU HAVE TO
SUPPORT WITNESSES- I THINK
THEY'RE HERE IN THE CHAMBER SO-
IS MISTER PATRICK FOY. HERE TO
PLEASE GO AHEAD MR FOR. A
GERMAN DALY PATRICK FOY I'M A
WILDLIFE OFFICER BY MY NORMAL
JOB A TODAY AND REPRESENTING
THE FISHING GAME WARDEN
SUPERVISORS AND MANAGERS
ASSOCIATION. PRIMARY SPONSOR OF
AB THREE THREE FOUR. WHICH
PROVIDES A REBUTTABLE
PRESUMPTION THAT SKIN CANCER
BETWEEN PARK RANGERS AND-
WILDLIFE OFFICERS IS A RESULT
OF OCCUPATIONAL EXPOSURE TO THE
SUN WE SPEND TEN TWELVE
SOMETIMES FOURTEEN HOURS A DAY
AND THE DIRECT SUNLIGHT FOR
MANY DAYS OF THE OF OUR YEARS.
AT IN OUR CAREER. DURING OUR
OUR OUR OUR EMPLOYMENT. BURNHAM
ON AN INFILL WARDEN ALLEN ONE
GARDEN CONTRACTED MELANOMA DUE
TO HIS EXCESSIVE OCCUPATIONAL
EXPOSURE TO THE SUN HE'S A
SACRAMENTO WARDEN. AND HE
APPLIED FOR WORKERS COMP
COVERAGE- THAT COVERAGE WAS
DENIED. OVER THE NEXT YEAR AND
A HALF ALLEN FOUGHT MELANOMA
AND THEN HE ALSO FOUGHT THE
WORKERS COMP SYSTEM AND HE
THANKFULLY WAS ULTIMATELY
SUCCESSFUL IN THAT EFFORT AND
THAT DECISION TO DENY THE
WORKERS COMP COVERAGE WAS
OVERTURNED. JUST ONLY WEEKS
BEFORE HE LOST HIS LIFE TO
MELANOMA BUT HE DID KNOW THAT
HIS- HIS WIFE AND SURVIVING
CHILDREN WERE GOING TO RECEIVE
BETTER BENEFITS BECAUSE OF
THAT. DECISION ABOUT TEN YEARS
AGO I COULD PERSONALLY NO
LONGER IGNORE THE SCALY LESIONS
ON MY ARMS THAT JUST WOULDN'T
GO AWAY I NOW HAVE A RECORD OF
FIVE- SQUAMOUS CELL CARCINOMAS
IN ONE BASAL CELL CARCINOMA
REMOVED OFF OF MY- ARMS MY FACE
AND MY NECK. I ALSO HAVE GONE
THROUGH AN ADDITIONAL FIVE
TREATMENTS OF A COOKTOP GOAL-
CHEMOTHERAPY TO REMOVE
ADDITIONAL PRE CANCEROUS
LESIONS. I'M ONE OF MANY FELLOW
WILDLIFE OFFICERS OR EXPERIENCE
THE SAME- WE HAVE PROVIDED
SEVERAL PUBLISHED STUDIES TO
SUPPORT OCCUPATIONAL SUN
EXPOSURE AND- TO. THAT IT
CONTRIBUTES TO SKIN CANCER. AND
THEN I'LL LAST A CLOSE BY
SAYING THAT THE SAME REBUTTABLE
PRESUMPTION FOR SKIN CANCER
CURRENTLY EXIST FOR LIFEGUARDS
FOR. A STATE PARKS COUNTIES AND
CITIES AND ALSO EVERY POLICE
OFFICER SHERIFF'S DEPUTY.
CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY PATROL
OFFICER IS COVERED BY LABOR
CODE THREE TWO ONE TWO POINT
ONE WHICH STATES IN SHORT THAT
A CANCER INCLUDING SKIN CANCER
THAT DEVELOPS OR MANIFESTS
ITSELF. DUE TO OCCUPATIONAL
EXPOSURE TO OCCUR SYNERGEN AND
THIS CASE- SOLAR RADIATION. AS
A RESULT OF THAT OCCUPATION.
WE'RE NOT EVEN ASKING FOR THAT
FULL CANCER PRESUMPTION WE ARE
ONLY ASKING FOR THE SKIN CANCER
PRESUMPTION. SO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER MEMBER
MULLIN FOR. SUPPORTING AND
OFFERING THIS BILL AND WE ASK
THIS COMMITTEE FOR YOUR SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISTER FOR
ANDA. I SEE MS NIXON WALKING TO
THE MIKE PLEASE GO AHEAD MS
NIXON AS A SUPERVISING
SUPERVISING PARK RANGER. THESE
GO AHEAD THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME MY NAME IS LAUREN NIXON
SHOEMAKER I'M A SUPERVISING
STATE PARK POLICE OFFICER A
CALIFORNIA STATE PARKS AND THE
MELANOMA SURVIVOR AND AN
ADVOCATE FOR AB THREE THREE
FOUR FISH AND WILDLIFE WARDENS
STATE PARK PEACE OFFICERS ARE
REQUIRED TO SPEND LONG SHIFTS
EXPOSED TO ENVIRONMENTAL
ELEMENTS INCLUDING UNRELENTING
HEAT OF CALIFORNIA SUMMERS.
THEY DESERVE THEIR AVAILABLE
PRESUMPTION AB THREE THREE FOUR
TO PROVIDES. I'VE BEEN EMPLOYED
BY CALIFORNIA STATE PARKS IN A
PEACE OFFICER CAPACITY SINCE
TWENTY THIRTEEN. IN JULY OF
TWENTY FOURTEEN I HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY IN PLEASURE OF
MEETING OFFICER BLAKE BOTTOM.
LIKE WAS A DEDICATED OFFICER
FRIEND AND COLLEAGUE TO MANY
MORE IMPORTANTLY HE WAS A
FATHER HUSBAND AND SON. LAKE
CONTRACTED MELANOMA AS A RESULT
OF EXCESSIVE SUN EXPOSURE
DURING HIS COURSE OF EMPLOYMENT.
LIKE APPLY FOR COVERAGE FROM
CALIFORNIA WORKERS COMPENSATION
SYSTEM AND WAS DENIED. LAKE
APPEAL THE DENIAL ON JANUARY
EIGHTH TWENTY SEVENTEEN BLAKE
DIED A RESULT AS A RESULT OF
MELANOMA WITHOUT KNOWING THE
FINDINGS OF HIS APPEAL. IN LATE
JANUARY TWENTY SEVENTEEN THE
SAME WITH MY FRIENDS AND FELLOW
STATE PARK POLICE OFFICERS
TRAVELED FROM ACROSS THE STATE.
TO PARTICIPATE IN HONORING
COLOR REGARDING BLIX HONOR. I
RECEIVE MY MELANOMA DIAGNOSIS
AT THE AGE OF TWENTY SEVEN. I
HAD NO REGULAR MORE MY LEFT
BICEP REMOVED BY DERMATOLOGIST
THE DERMATOLOGIST CONFIRMED A
PRESUMPTIVE STAGE ONE MELANOMA
DIAGNOSIS THE TREATMENT FOR MY
CANCER WAS EMERGING REMOVAL AND
A SENTINEL LYMPH NODE BIOPSY. A
LARGE SCAR ON MY OUTER LEFT
BICEP IS A PHYSICAL REMINDER OF
MY CANCER. THE PSYCHOLOGICAL
REMINDERS OF BEING A HIGH RISK
FOR REOCCURRENCE OR SPREAD ARE
INDESCRIBABLE. MY INCREASING
THE COVERAGE WERE RESPONDED TO
WITH RANGERS ARE NOT INCLUDED
IF I'D BEEN A LIFE GUARD
EMPLOYED BY MY DEPARTMENT. THE
REPEAT REBUTTABLE PRESUMPTION
WOULD HAVE EXISTED. MY
EXPERIENCE IS ONE FOR MANY
WARDENS AND RANGERS WHO WORK TO
PROTECT THE BIOLOGICAL
DIVERSITY AND THE NATURAL AND
OR AND OR HISTORICAL LANDSCAPES
OF THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. AS
REFLECTED IN THE EVIDENCE
PRESENTED AND DOCUMENTATION
PROVIDED. AB THREE THREE FOUR
ETHNOLOGIST THREE BUBBLE
PRESUMPTION WARDENS AND RANGERS
ENCOUNTER WITHIN THE
REQUIREMENTS OF OUR EMPLOYMENT
I ENCOURAGE YOU TO SUPPORT
WILDLIFE OFFICERS AND PARK
RANGERS ON THIS IMPORTANT BILL.
THANK YOU MS NIXON AND- ARE
THERE ANY- OPPOSE WITNESSES
HERE PRESIDENT. OR IN ROOM ONE
TWENTY FIVE. THIRTY PERSONS WHO
WISH TO OPPOSE. MISTER MULLIN
DO YOU ARE YOU AWARE OF ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
THAT WISH TO COMMENT- I'M NOT
SURE IF THEY WERE GOING TO BE A
FEW FOLKS CALLING IN. I'VE I
BELIEVE THERE MAY BUT I DON'T
WANT TO BELABOR THIS ALL RIGHT
HEARING ANY LONG THANK YOU AND
EXCUSE ME FOR JUMPING AROUND A
LITTLE BIT BUT I YOU KNOW I
JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE WE GIVE
EVERYONE AN OPPORTUNITY- I SEE
ONE ADDITIONAL PERSON- ARE YOU.
IN OPPOSE OR SUPPORT GOOD
MORNING MISTER CHAIR JENNIFER
FAN I ACTUALLY WANTED TO LIST A
NUMBER OF ORGANIZATIONS THAT
ARE HERE. ASKED ME TO CONVEY
THEIR SUPPORT. IS GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS. LIKE THAT- I URGE THE
COMMITTEE TO VOTE IN SUPPORT OF
AB THREE THREE FOUR ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA WILDLIFE
OFFICERS FOUNDATION. THE
MOUNTAIN LION FOUNDATION OSHANA
DEFENDERS OF WILDLIFE THE
ENDANGERED HABITATS LEAGUE
FRIENDS OF FISHING GAME AND THE
CALIFORNIA SEA URCHIN
COMMISSION THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. LET'S GO TO OUR
PHONE LINE AND MAKE SURE WE'VE
WE'VE- GIVING EVERYONE A
CHANCE- LET'S GO TO THE SUPPORT-
GROUP FIRST. ON THE PHONE LINE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND ZERO AT THIS TIME PRESS
ONE BUTTON. ZERO I WILL FIRST
GO TO THE LINE OF TWENTY FIVE
LINE TWENTY FIVE YOUR LINES
OPEN. IF YOU'RE SHARING MEMBERS
JENNIFER ROWE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATEWIDE LAW
ENFORCEMENT ASSOCIATION AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. LINE.
TWENTY NINE. MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS THIS IS REALLY GREAT
BUT THE CALIFORNIA RIFLE AND
PISTOL ASSOCIATION ALSO RETIRED
GAME WARDENS AT SEVERAL THESE
REMOVED IN VERY STRONG SUPPORT
OF THIS EFFORT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. LINE THIRTY FIVE. THIS IS
YOUR MEMBERS MARKEL SMITH ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
WATERFOWL ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. LINE.
THIRTY FOUR. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS WITHOUT ELEVEN
PALACE WITH THE NATURE
CONSERVANCY IMPROPER PART OF AB
THREE THREE FOUR AND WE THANK
OTHERS WHO TESTIFIED FOR SHERRY
DIFFERENT BILL. THANK YOU. LINE.
THIRTY THREE. HELLO MY NAME IS-
DANNY STEVENSON GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS I LIVE IN
MADERA COUNTY AND I AM ALSO-
WHILE MY FATHER. WHAT THE
DEPARTMENT OFFICIAL WILDLIFE
AND I URGE YOU TO SUPPORT AB
THREE THREE FOUR ALSO SKIN
CANCER. SURVIVOR AS WELL THREE
TIMES. THANK YOU SIR. WHAT ONCE
AGAIN LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
MISTER CHAIR THERE IS NO ONE
ELSE COULD SIGNAL THAT THEY
WISH TO SPEAK. AND HOW ABOUT ON
THE OPPOSING SIDE IS THAT
INCLUDE OPPOSE A. PERSONS AS
WELL. APPARENTLY SO THE MOMENT
MR CARE. FOR THOSE OF YOU IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
PRESS ONE AND ZERO IF YOU WISH
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION. MISTER
CHAIR NO ONE IS SIGNALED THAT
THEY WISH TO SPEAK. GOOD THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- THAT CONCLUDES
OUR- WITNESS TESTIMONY IN
SUPPORT AND OPPOSE TESTIMONY
COMMITTEE MEMBERS DO YOU HAVE
ANY QUESTIONS ON THIS BILL MR
FRAZIER AS QUESTION. YES MATURE
THANK YOU QUESTION OF THE
AUTHOR. WHEREAS WE ALL
ACKNOWLEDGE THE EXPOSURE LEVELS
THAT THE WARDENS ARE TAKING. AS
WHICH IS YOU KNOW. UNFORTUNATE
THAT THEY'VE BEEN HIT WITH A
SELECTION WHAT IS THE AGENCY
DOING AS A RISK MANAGEMENT TO
REDUCE THEIR EXPOSURE OR TRY TO
HELP THIS AS A PREVENTION
MEASURE- GOING FORWARD SO THE
YOU KNOW. WE DON'T HAVE TO HAVE
TO WORRY ABOUT PRESUMPTION WE
DON'T HAVE TO WORRY ABOUT THEM
BEING AFFLICTED. WHAT WHAT CAN
THE AGENCY DO TO BETTER
PROTECT. THE WARDENS. WELL
THANK YOU FOR THAT QUESTION-
NEVER FRAZIER- I DON'T HAVE A
PRECISE ANSWER FOR YOU NOT
KNOWING THOSE INTERNAL
DISCUSSIONS I DO KNOW THERE IS
AN INTERNAL EVIDENCE THAT HAS
PROMPTED THIS DISCUSSION THAT
HAS PROMPTED THIS THERE'S A
HEIGHTENED AWARENESS WITHIN
THESE DEPARTMENTS AMONG THESE
OFFICERS THAT THIS IS INDEED A
RISK THAT THIS IS AN ONGOING.
CHALLENGE BUT IT SEEMS TO ME
THAT THEIR- IT'S VERY MUCH-
WHILE THERE'S AN AWARENESS
THERE IT'S VERY MUCH UP TO
THESE OFFICES ON THEIR OWN TO
TAKE A SERIES OF PRECAUTIONS
AGAINST THE AGAINST THE UV RAYS
SELL- CLEARLY THERE'S A LOT OF
WORK TO BE DONE IN THIS AREA
BUT- IT IN MY WAY OF THINKING
IT JUST STANDS TO REASON. THAT
THIS HEIGHTENED RISK OF HAS LED
TO THIS BILL BUT AGAIN I DO
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THIS IS
BASED IN SCIENCE AS THE CHAIR
IS INDICATED AS I'VE INDICATED
OF AND WE WILL NOT MOVE FORWARD
UNLESS THE SCIENCE BACKS UP.
THIS INTERNAL EVIDENCE. WHAT
MISTER LOAN SO WHAT AND I AGREE
WITH YOU I ABSOLUTELY AGREE
WITH YOU THAT WE NEED TO MAKE
SURE THAT IT DOESN'T AFFECT
AFFECTION FOR AFFECTED BY THEIR
THEIR WORK THAT THEY SHOULD BE
COVERED ABSOLUTELY I'VE BEEN A
HUNTER FOR FIFTY ONE YEARS AND
HAVE HAD GREAT EXPERIENCES IN
THE OUTDOORS BECAUSE OF THIS
AGENCY. WHAT I WANT TO KNOW IS.
HOW PROACTIVE IN OUR ROLE AS
OVERSIGHT OF THIS AGENCY CAN WE
MAKE SURE THAT THEY'RE DOING
EVERYTHING THEY CAN TO PROTECT
THESE PUBLIC SERVICE.
ADMINISTRATOR I MISS CHAIR IF I
MAY UM IF PAT COULD MORE
DIRECTLY ADDRESSED- THAT
QUESTION MY UNDERSTANDING IS
THAT YOU KNOW THEY'RE FOR THE
BASIC THINGS LIKE HATS BUT IT
HITS REALLY VERY MUCH A TO THE
WORKERS THEMSELVES FOR CERTAIN
PROTECTIONS BUT PAT DO YOU HAVE
A AN ADDITIONAL ANSWER ON THAT.
I CAN TELL YOU THAT OUR UNIFORM
POLICY ON COURSE AUTHORIZES
LONG SLEEVES WHICH MANY OF US
I'VE BEEN WEARING LONG SLEEVES
FOR OUTDOOR WORK FOR YEARS NOW.
ADD I CERTAINLY HATS- BUT
SUNSCREEN IS REALLY THE PRIMARY
TOOL WE HAVE BUT THE PROBLEM
WITH SUNSCREEN IS THAT SALT
SPRAY- JUST DIRT GRIME SWEAT-
WEARING LONG SLEEVES IN THE
HEAT OF SUMMER IS IT JUST
MISERABLY UNCOMFORTABLE AND
THEN IT WASHES OFF IT GETS
WASHED UP WITH THE DIRT AND
SWEAT. AND DEFINITELY THE SALT
SPRAY SO IT'S JUST IT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE ALL ARE AWARE
OF THE DEPARTMENT DOES. THEY
MAKE SURE WE ARE AWARE OF THAT
AUTHORIZING THE HATS
AUTHORIZING LONG SLEEVES BUT IT
JUST IT USUALLY JUST NOT ENOUGH.
ALL RIGHT. MR FRAZIER. ARE YOU.
GOOD GOOD AND- MISTER COOPER-
GOOD GOOD ANY OTHER COMMITTEE
COMMENTS- WELL TO THE MEMBER
FROM SOUTH SAN FRANCISCO- WE'VE
HAD A PRETTY THOROUGH
DISCUSSION IS THERE ANYTHING
YOU'D LIKE TO ADD AND CLOSING-
NOVATION CHAIR JUST APPRECIATE
YOU ENTERTAINING- THIS POLICY
AND AGAIN THAT- REITERATE THE
COMMITMENT ABOUT THE STUDY ON
THE SENATE SIDE. AND THE
PROGRESS OF THE BILL SO THANK
YOU FOR YOUR WORK MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS AND I ASK FOR I HAVE A-
BEAUTIFUL- WE HAVE A MOTION IN
SECONDS LET'S. LET'S VOTE. AB
THREE THREE FOUR. DO YOU PASSED
YOUR PREPARATIONS DALY AYE DALY
AYE MAYES. BERMAN BIGELOW
BIGELOW AYE CHAN CHEN I COOLEY
COOLEY AYE COOPER COOPER AYE
FRAZIER FRAZIER I GIPSON.
GIPSON I AGREE SENATE. GRAYSON
AYE RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ AYE
VOEPEL VOEPEL I WOULD. TEN
ZERO. THERE WAS A TEN ZERO VOTE
WITH A FEW MEMBERS YET TO ADD
ON WITH THEIR VOTE THANK YOU.
MISTER MOLOT. THE NEXT BILL IS-
AB ONE TEN BY MISS PETRI NORRIS.
THE MEMBER FROM LAGUNA BEACH
CALIFORNIA. PART OF THE OC
DELEGATION LIKE MISTER CHAIR
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I'M HERE TODAY TO ASK
YOUR SUPPORT FOR AB ONE TEN
WHICH IS A VERY STRAIGHTFORWARD
MEASURE WHICH WOULD REQUIRE
CALIFORNIA'S EMPLOYMENT
DEVELOPMENT DEPARTMENT Q. CROSS
CHECK UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE
CLAIMS AGAINST INCARCERATION.
CONSTITUENTS HAVE WATCHED WITH
HORROR AND OUTRAGE THE MYRIAD
WAYS IN WHICH I CALIFORNIA'S
EMPLOYMENT DEVELOPMENT
DEPARTMENT HAS FAILED
CALIFORNIANS THROUGHOUT THIS
PANDEMIC ONE OF THE MOST
EGREGIOUS EXAMPLES WAS THE-
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
ESTIMATED NOW TO BE EIGHT
HUNDRED MILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE FRAUD
RELATED TO PAYMENTS TO. IN THE
NAMES OF INCARCERATED
CALIFORNIANS IN A RECENT STATE
AUDIT BY THE AUDITOR IDENTIFIED
THE FACT THAT THE REASON THAT
THIS FAILURE OCCURRED IS THAT
THE EMPLOYMENT DEVELOPMENT
DEPARTMENT DOES NOT HAVE A
PROCESS IN PLACE TO CROSS CHECK
CLAIMS AGAINST INCARCERATION
RECORDS SO THE PURPOSE OF THIS
BILL IS TO CLOSE THAT CRITICAL
GAP AND ENSURE THAT TAX WE
AVOID A FRAUD TO BOTTLE LIKE
THIS FROM EVER HAPPENING AGAIN
IT'S A SIMPLE AND COMMON SENSE
APPROACH AND DATA. COMMONSENSE
STEP WITH THAT I AM PLEASED. TO
INTRODUCE FOR TESTIMONY. LESLIE
YOUNG WHO IS THE ASSISTANT
DISTRICT ATTORNEY FROM ORANGE
COUNTY. GOOD THANK YOU. MS
YOUNG ARE YOU ON THE PHONE LINE.
YES I AM YEAH PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
LESLIE YOUNG ORANGE COUNTY
ASSISTANT DISTRICT ATTORNEY IN
CHARGE OF MAJOR FRAUD ON BEHALF
OF DISTRICT ATTORNEY TODD
SPITZER I STRONGLY URGE AN AYE
VOTE ON AB ONE TEN. IN NOVEMBER
TWENTY TWENTY DISTRICT ATTORNEY
SPENCER DIRECTED THE MAJORITY
OF OUR FRAUD UNITS RESOURCES BE
USED TO INVESTIGATE AND
PROSECUTE FRAUDULENT
APPLICATIONS FOR UNEMPLOYMENT
BENEFITS BY INMATES IN
CALIFORNIA PRISONS OUR OFFICE
UNCOVERED OVER A MILLION
DOLLARS IN FRAUDULENT
UNEMPLOYMENT BENEFITS PAID TO
THE INMATES COCONSPIRATORS IN
ORANGE COUNTY ALONE. WE FILED
MULTIPLE FELONY CHARGES AGAINST
EIGHT INDIVIDUALS IN THE SCHEME
BUT DESPITE NUMEROUS BANK
SEARCH WARRANTS AND OTHER
INVESTIGATIVE EFFORTS TO
FRAUDULENTLY DIVERTED FUNDS HAD
VANISHED. ALTHOUGH WE
ANTICIPATE OBTAINING
RESTITUTION ORDERS ON BEHALF OF
EDT THE REALITY IS THAT MOST IF
NOT ALL OF THAT MONEY WILL
NEVER BE RETURNED TO TAXPAYERS.
DURING OUR EXTENSIVE
INVESTIGATION WE LEARNED THAT
THESE EIGHT SUSPECTS BY THE TIP
OF THE ICEBERG OF A RAMPANT
STATEWIDE FRAUDULENT
UNEMPLOYMENT CLAIMS SCHEME
INVOLVING STATE PRISONER
APPLICANTS. HAD A MECHANISM
BEEN IN PLACE TO BLOCK THIS
MONEY FOR DISTRIBUTION TO
INELIGIBLE PRISON INMATES
UNTOLD MILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN
BENEFITS WOULD HAVE BEEN
SAFEGUARDED AND THOUSANDS OF
HOURS OF INVESTIGATIVE
RESOURCES DEVOTED ELSEWHERE. AB
ONE TEN IS A COMMONSENSE
SOLUTION TO THIS PROBLEM AND IS
ABSOLUTELY ESSENTIAL IN
MINIMIZING THE LOSS OF TAXPAYER
DOLLARS TO FRAUD. UNEMPLOYMENT
BENEFITS MUST BE AVAILABLE TO
HELP OUT OF WORK CALIFORNIANS
NOT TO ENRICH INCARCERATED
CRIMINALS AND THEIR ASSOCIATES.
WE THINK ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PETRIE-NORRIS FOR BRINGING THIS
IMPORTANT LEGISLATION AND
STRONGLY URGE AN AYE VOTE ON AB
ONE TEN THANK YOU. THANK YOU MS
YOUNG- DOES THE MEMBER FROM
LAGUNA BEACH HAVE ANY OTHER
SUPPORT WITNESSES- WE DO NOT.
THANK YOU. THEN THIS IS AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR AN OPPOSE A
WITNESS WHO HAS NOTIFIED US IN
ADVANCE- MISS KATIE DIXON ARE
YOU ON THE PHONE. YES GOOD
MORNING I'M HERE. GO AHEAD
MYSTICS IN. THANK YOU SO MUCH
AND AGAIN GOOD MORNING
COMMITTEE CHAIRED DALY AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS ALIKE AND
THANK YOU AS WELL ASSEMBLY
MEMBER PETRIE-NORRIS AND ALL
THE MEMBERS WHO ARE CALLED
SPONSORING OR CO AUTHORING THIS
IMPORTANT LEGISLATION. MY NAME
IS KATIE DIXON I'M A COMMUNITY
ORGANIZER WITH LEGAL AID AT
WORK I'M A FORMERLY
INCARCERATED CALIFORNIA
UNFORTUNATELY HERE TO OPPOSE AB
ONE FAN. LEGAL AID AT WORK IS A
NONPROFIT LEGAL SERVICE
ORGANIZATION I HAVE BEEN
ASSISTING LOW INCOME WORKING
FAMILIES FOR MORE THAN A
HUNDRED YEARS. AND AS A PART OF
OUR SERVICES WE INVITE
INDIVIDUALS SEEKING
UNEMPLOYMENT BENEFITS AND ALSO
REPRESENT INDIVIDUALS ARE
WRONGFULLY DENIED THESE
BENEFITS. WE APOLOGIZE AB ONE
FAN WHICH REQUIRES ACROSS MATCH
AND VERIFICATION SYSTEM BY
SHARING THE NINETY FOUR
SECURITY NUMBER OF PEOPLE
BETWEEN CDC ARE. AN EDT BEFORE
MAKING ANY UNEMPLOYMENT
COMPENSATION BENEFITS THAT THE
CLAIMANT IS NOT CURRENTLY
INCARCERATED PERSON. WE ARE ALL
TROUBLED BY THE RECENT
INCIDENTS OF FRAUD. BUT I ALSO
WANT FOLKS TO REALLY TAKE A
LOOK AT INCARCERATED PEOPLE
WERE VICTIMS OF THIS FRAUD AND
HAD THEIR INFORMATION USED TO
APPLY FOR THESE BENEFITS
WITHOUT THEIR KNOWLEDGE AND
CONSENT. DESPITE THE TROUBLING
NATURE OF THIS RECENT ACTIVITY
BCFS WERE FAR LARGELY LIMITED
TO THE PANDEMIC UNEMPLOYMENT
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM. THAT THE
EDT ITSELF IS ESTIMATED AT
ROUGHLY 95% OF BROUGHT WERE
PAID OUT WITH THIS PROGRAM. THE
REMAINING 5% HAS BEEN
ATTRIBUTED TO THE REGULAR U. Y.
PROGRAM. WOW WE DO WANT TO SEE
THIS IF THIS BUSY BENEFITS
SHOULD BE AVAILABLE TO ALL
CALIFORNIA. NEVER THE LESS
PROVIDING EDT ACCESS TO
INCARCERATED PEOPLE'S
INFORMATION FOR THE PURPOSES OF
YOU WHY PROGRAM VERIFICATION IS
NOT THE WAY TO SOLVE. WE REALLY
BELIEVE THAT THIS BILL MAY
PREVENT LEGITIMATE CLAIMS FOR
UNEMPLOYMENT BENEFITS AND LEAD
TO THE WRONGFUL DENIAL OF A
CRITICAL SAFETY NET FOR
FORMERLY INCARCERATED PEOPLE
LIKE MYSELF. WHO ALREADY FACE
PARTICULARLY HARDSHIP WHEN
GETTING BACK INTO THE LABOR
MARKET INTO THE LABOR MARKET
EXCUSE ME. WHAT CONCERNS THE
BILL WILL LEAD TO THE NIGHT
BECAUSE THE DELAYS ARE PORTING
AND OR ERRORS. RECORDKEEPING
ERRORS IN OUR IN OUR STATE-
JUSTICE SYSTEM IS WELL
DOCUMENTED. THE NUMBER OF
INACCURACIES INCOMPLETE BALLOT
IN A LACK OF CONTINUUM OF CARE.
IS THE AS HIS FRIENDS MADE
ACROSS MANY DIFFERENT PLATFORMS
IS A SOUND. ACCORDING TO THE
FEDERAL CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM
IN A TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN
STUDY REPORT. THE AVERAGE OF
50% OF A RISK IF THEY DATABASES
AND A MISSING DISPOSITION
INFORMATION. THAT THE HIGH
NUMBER. THE REQUIREMENT THAT HE
BE NOTIFIED THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE THAT CDC ARE WHEN THEY
DETERMINE OR THINK OF CLAIMING
IS CURRENTLY INCARCERATED. IT'S
ALSO TROUBLING TO US AS IT IS
ALSO READY AS THEY ALSO CALLED
FOR AN ADDITIONAL USE OF
ALREADY LIMITED EDT RESOURCES
AND MAKE FURTHER CRIMINALIZE
FORMALLY INCARCERATED OR
CURRENTLY INCARCERATED. MYSTICS
IN THE NATION ARE YOU CURRENTLY
pWRAP IT UP PLEASE. THAT THEY
THINK OUR I WAS IT UP I JUST
WANTED TO ENOUGH AND THAT THE
DISSEMINATION OF OUR RECORDS.
THESE RECORDS ARE ALREADY ALL
OVER THE PLACE WERE ALREADY
STRUGGLING TO KEEP A HOLD OF
THESE RECORDS. AND WE REALLY
FEEL LIKE IT'S WHICH IS ALSO
LEAD TO OUR INFORMATION THE
APARTMENT USE THAT METHOD BE.
THEY YOU SO MUCH FOR THESE
REASONS WE OPPOSE AB ONE FAN.
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING TO WORK WITH
EVERYONE ON THIS. IMPORTANT
ISSUE THANK YOU SO MUCH AND
MISS DICKSON THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PARTICIPATION IN THE HEARING
IN- FOR YOUR- YOUR SUMMARY OF-
OF WHY YOU'RE OPPOSED TO THE
BILL- ARE THERE ANY OTHER
PERSONS ARE WISHING TO OPPOSE
THIS BILL. VIA OUR PHONE. HER
CUP. MISTER ROBERTS THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR FOR THOSE OF YOU
WHO WISH TO SPEAK AN OPPOSITE-
AND SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE
NINE ZERO AT THIS TIME PRESS
ONE TWO ZERO IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT. WELL NOW HERE
FROM LINE FORTY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS WHO SHALL MUTCHLER ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
SHERIFFS ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
OF ASSEMBLY BILL ONE K. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. LINE. SIXTEEN
BONTA KRAMER MATER ON BEHALF OF
ACLU CALIFORNIA ACTION IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. AND IF
THERE'S ANYONE ELSE THAT WISHES
TO SPEAK PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO AT THISTIME PRESS. ONE
NINE ZERO. MISTER CHAIR THERE
IS NO ONE ELSE THAT SIGNAL BUT
THEY WISH TO SPEAK. THANK YOU.
WE HAVE A MOTION AND SECOND ON
THIS BILL- COMMITTEE MEMBERS
ANY QUESTIONS FOR THE AUTHOR.
ALL RIGHT TO. MISS PTRI NORRIS
ANY CLOSING REMARKS OR OTHER
POINTS TO ME I'LL JUST I'LL
I'LL I'LL BRIEFLY ADDRESS A
COUPLE OF THE POINTS THAT THAT
MYSTICS AND REYES- NUMBER ONE
SHE'S ABSOLUTELY RIGHT THAT IN
SOME CASES- INCARCERATED
INDIVIDUALS WERE A PART OF THE
RINGS PERPETRATING THESE CRIMES
IN OTHER CASES INCARCERATED
INDIVIDUALS ACTUALLY THE
VICTIM'S IDENTITY THEFT IN
THESE CRIMES ARE PERPETRATED IN
THEIR NAME AND WHAT'S IMPORTANT
IS THAT THIS BILL WILL ENSURE
THAT BOTH OF THOSE THINGS STOP
HAPPENING- AND SAID THAT.
INCARCERATED INDIVIDUALS THAT
HAVE BEEN VICTIMIZED BY THIS
WOULD ALSO BE PROTECTED BY THIS
MEASURE ON AND SECONDLY AT
MYSTICS AND RAISED SOME
CONCERNS ABOUT DATA INTEGRITY
ACROSS OUR STATE AGENCIES AND I
KNOW THAT THAT CERTAINLY IS A
THE TERROR OF THE ASSEMBLY
ACCUNTABILITY COMMITTEE AN
AREA OF FOCUS FOR ME AND
SOMETHING THAT WE NEED TO.
ENSURE THAT WE ROUTE WE HAVE
THAT WE RECTIFY ANY GAPS AND
ISSUES BUT- I THINK POINTING TO
EXISTING FAILURES IN STATE
AGENCIES AS A RATIONALE FOR
PILING ON EVEN MORE ABOUT
POLICY DOES NOT SEEM LOGICAL ON
SO I WOULD WOULD ALSO JUST AT
ANYTHING CLOSE I KNEW ASSEMBLY
MEMBER TEN HE'S PART OF THIS
COMMITTEE IT INTRODUCED AT A
SIMILAR MEASURE AND ON HIS NOW
SIGNED ON AS A DOING AUTHOR
THIS TO THANK YOU FOR YOUR WORK
ON THIS ISSUE. AND DIVE WITH
THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
LIKE A- GOOD- I AM RECOMMENDING
SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE WE HAVE
A MOTION AND SECOND IF THERE
ARE NO FURTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS LET'S GO AHEAD VOTE.
AB ONE TEN IS DO PASTOR
PREPARATIONS DALY OUR DAILY AYE
MAYES. BERMAN BIGELOW BIGELOW
AYE CHAN AYE CHAN AYE COOLEY.
COOLEY AYE COOPER COOPER AYE
FRAZIER FRAZIER AYE GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE GRAYSON GRAYSON AYE
RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ AYE VOEPEL
VOEPEL I WOULD WOULD I. THANK
YOU ELEVEN ZERO. THAT WAS
ELEVEN TO ZERO MISS PETRI
NORRIS WITH A FEW MEMBERS YET
TO ADD ON. SO WELL DONE. BRINGS
US TO THE LAST BILL- ON THE
AGENDA- AB EIGHT SEVEN TWO BY
MISTER WOULD. WE HAVE A MOBILE
WE HAVE A MOTION AND SECOND SO
YOU'RE ON A ROLL SIR THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
AS SOMEONE WHO'S PERSONALLY
BEEN EVACUATED FROM MY HOME TOO
MANY TIMES- AND- THERE'S
NOTHING LIKE THE- THE SITE OF
FLAMES IN THE DISTANCE- TO GET
YOUR- BLOOD PRESSURE UP AND- I
WILL ALWAYS BE THANKFUL FOR THE
SACRIFICES FIREFIGHTERS WE
COUNT ON TO KEEP OUR HOMES IN
OUR COMMUNITY SAFE.
UNFORTUNATELY SOME FIREFIGHTERS
DO GET INJURED ON THE JOB AND
WHEN THEY DO THEIR ONLY FOCUS
SHOULD BE ON RECOVERING SO THEY
CAN RETURN TO WORK AT A 100%
AND NOT WORRY ABOUT ANY
FINANCIAL HARDSHIP THAT THEIR
ENTRY MAY HAVE COST. AB EIGHT
SEVENTY TWO WOULD AUTHORIZE AL
FIRE FIREFIGHTERS WHOSE
PRINCIPAL DUTIES INCLUDE ACTIVE
FIRE SUPPRESSION OR PREVENTION
SERVICES I SEE THE WHOLE WAGE
FOR A YEAR IF THEY SHOULD
BECOME INJURED ON THE JOB. THIS
BILL WOULD BRING CAL FIRE FIRE
FIRE FIRE FIGHTERS HAVE TO PART
WITH OTHER PUBLIC SAFETY
EMPLOYEES SUCH AS C. H. P.
FISHING GAME WARDENS LIFEGUARDS
AS WELL AS OUR FELLOW
FIREFIGHTER FIREFIGHTERS. WHO
ARE EMPLOYED BY LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS. AB EIGHT SEVENTY
TWO GIVES DIGNITY AND RESPECT
OF THE CALIFORNIA FIREFIGHTERS
THAT ARE USUALLY THE FRONT LINE
OF DEFENSE. AND PUT THEIR LIVES
ON THE LINE FIGHTING FIRES. ON
THE PHONE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
AS PRESIDENT TIM EDWARDS WITH
CAL FIRE TO EIGHT EIGHT ONE.
THIS BILL HAS NO OPPOSITION I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
WE HAVE A MOTION AND SECOND TO
PASS THIS BILL I HAVE
RECOMMENDED. SUPPORT FOR THIS
BILL AND- MISTER TIM EDWARDS
YOU'RE WELCOME TO GO AHEAD WITH
YOUR SUPPORT TESTIMONY. YES
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR A
COMMITTEE MEMBER CAN YOU HEAR
ME. YES YES PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU HI. MY NAME TIM
EDWARDS PRESIDENT OF CAL FIRE
LOCAL TWENTY EIGHT EIGHTY ONE
REPRESENTING THE PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS OF CALIFORNIA.
EIGHTY EIGHT SEVENTY TWO
CORRECT THE WRONG. CURRENTLY
GOVERNMENT CODE FORTY EIGHT
HUNDRED EXCLUDES GALPHARM
FIREFIGHTERS FROM THE SAME
PROTECTIONS AS ARE OTHER FELLOW
PUBLIC SAFETY EMPLOYEES. WE ARE
ASKING FOR SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
TO BRING IT IN LINE WITH OTHER
PUBLIC SAFETY EMPLOYEES
INCLUDING CHP STATE PARK
MISTAKE FISHING GAME PROTECTING-AS IF THE JOB OF INJURY SHOULD
OCCUR WE CURRENTLY WORK THE
SEVENTY TWO HOUR WORK WEEK THE
LONGEST SHIFT PATTERN IN THE
FIRE SERVICE IN THE- UNITED
STATES. THE STORK BUYER TO
PROVING THAT WE RISK OUR LIFE
EVERY DAY BUT ARE NOT PROTECTED
UNDER THE SAME EQUAL RIGHTS AS
OUR PUBLIC SAFETY COUNTERPART
WE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT ON THIS BILL AND THINK
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WITH FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD. I STAND
BY FOR ANY QUESTIONS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER EDWARDS- MR
WOULD ARE THERE ANY OTHER OF-
SUPPORTERS THAT YOU'RE AWARE OF
WHO WANT TO TESTIFY JUST
HUNDREDS OF FIREFIGHTERS BUT
THEY'RE NOT ON THE PHONE. ALL
RIGHT- I'LL GO TO WAR OUR
OPERATOR WHICH WHICH YOU WERE
INQUIRE SIR WHETHER THERE ARE
ANY ADDITIONAL SUPPORTERS WHO
ARE HOOKED IN BY PHONE. IF
ANYONE WISHES TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE NINE
ZERO PRESS ONE ZERO. WILL NOW
GO TO LINE THIRTY NINE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
OUT TAKE THIRTY SECONDS AARON
READ PROUDLY REPRESENTING THE
CALFIRE FIREFIGHTERS FOR FORTY
YEARS AND I JUST DID- WHAT OUR
PRESIDENT TIM EDWARDS SAID
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TIME TODAY. THANK YOU MISTER
REED. LINE FORTY FIVE. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS
THIS IS DOUG SERVERS ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS IN STRONG SUPPORT
WITH ECHO THE COMMENTS PRESENT
WORKS THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISTRESS TUBERS. FINAL CALL FOR
ANYONE WHO WISHES TO SPEAK AT
THIS TIME PLEASE PRESS. ONE
ZERO. MISTER CHAIR THERE IS NO
ONE ELSE WOULD SIGNAL BUT THEY
WISH TO SPEAK. DOES THAT
INCLUDE THE OPPOSE SIDE AS WELL.
HOW I WILL PUT OUT THE INVITE
AGAIN LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
PLEASE PRESS ONE VENTURA PRESS
ONE ZERO IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION. MISTER CHAIR
THERE IS NO NEWS WHO SIGNALED
THEY WISH TO SPEAK THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- AS I SAID AT THE
BEGINNING OF THE MEETING I'M
RECOMMENDING SUPPORT OF THIS
MEASURE. I UNDERSTAND THAT MR
BIGELOW HAS A COMMENT OR A
QUESTION GO AHEAD SIR. THANK
YOU AYE MR CHAIRMAN TO THE
AUTHOR- FIRST THANK YOU FOR
REMEMBERING OUR FIREFIGHTERS
AND BRING HIM INTO PARITY WITH
OTHERS- I'D LIKE TO BE A CO
AUTHOR ON THIS- I THINK THAT
THIS S A- VERY MERITORIOUS.
BILL AND IF YOU'RE SO INCLINED
TO ACCEPT COOPER SIGHED HAPPILY
BE. I'D BE HAPPY TO HAVE YOU
MISTER BIGELOW THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT. THANK MR RODRIGUEZ- HAS
A COMMON INNOCENT THINK MISTER
GIBSON AS A COMMENT TO GO AHEAD
MRS RANA THANKS AUTHOR ONCE
AGAIN FOR BRINGING THIS BILL
FORWARD ARE FORTUNATE I'VE HAD
THAT MANY OPPORTUNITIES WORK
SIDE BY SIDE SOME OF THESE
FIREFIGHTERS ARE SEEING
FIRSTHAND. ALL THE HARD WORK
THEY DO DAY IN AND DAY OUT AND
SOMETIMES WE FORGET ABOUT WHAT
THEY DO WITH FIRE SEASON
APPROACHING THAT'S GOING TO BE
DIFFICULT ONE MORE TIME SO ALSO
LIKE TO BE. ADDED AS A CO
AUTHOR IF IT'S POSSIBLE THANK
YOU FOR BRINGING THIS BEFORE
THANK YOU MISS RODRIGUEZ
ABSOLUTELY. ALL RIGHT MISTER
GIBSON HAS A COMMENT. IF YOU
FOR. VERY MUCH RESTAURANTS WHEN
I ONLINE MY COMMENTS WITH THE
MEMBERS. OF ALREADY ASKED TO BE
A CO AUTHOR. OF LIKE TO BE
CONSIDERED JOINT- AND CERTAINLY
WE BELIEVE IN THIS BILL AFTER
READING THIS IS VERY GOOD
POLICY AND- IS SUPPORT OF OUR
FIREFIGHTERS NOT THINK THAT
THIS IS A GREAT MEASURE AND
LOOK FORWARD TO SEEING IT. GO
TO LESSEN THE PROCESS WITH
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MISTER GIPSON YEP YEP. WE
HAVE THIRDS AND FOURTHS NOW
WARRANTED SHAPE ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS- LET'S
MISTER WOULD ANYTHING ELSE
YOU'D LIKE TO ADD BEFORE WE
VOTE WELL FIRST OF ALL THANK
YOU TO SUPPORT MY COLLEAGUES
HERE I WOULD SAY THIS IS REALLY
THIS REALLY ISN'T JUST AN
EQUITY ISSUE THESE ARE BENEFITS
THAT ARE SUPPLIED TO OTHER
OTHER OTHER PUBLIC SAFETY-
WORKERS OUT THERE. AND I WOULD
SAY THIS YOU KNOW I THINK SO
FIREFIGHTERS OF THE HARDEST
WORKING PEOPLE I'VE EVER SEEN
TRUST ME THEY WANT TO GET BACK
ON THE FIRE LINE AND DO
EVERYTHING THEY CAN TO PROTECT
YOU THEY SHOULDN'T HAVE TO
WORRY ABOUT THEIR OWN HEALTH
THEIR OWN THEIR OWN THEIR OWN
INCOME IN THEIR OWN HEALTH AND
SAFETY. TO BE ABLE TO DO THAT
SO- I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE. GOOD THANK YOU SIR IN.
ROLL CALL VOTE PLEASE. AB EIGHT
SEVEN TO DO PASS APPROPRIATIONS
DALY AYE DALY AYE MAYES MAYES
AYE BERMAN BERMAN AYE BIGELOW.
BIGELOW AYE CHAN CHAN I COOLEY
COOLEY AYE COOPER. COOPER AYE
FRAZIER FRAZIER AYE GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE GRAYSON GRAYSON AYE
RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ AYE VOEPEL
WELL I WOULD I WOULD I.
THIRTEEN SO THE MINISTER SHOW A
COUPLE OF THOSE VOTES ARE IN
BOLD FACE RIGHT OKAY THIRTEEN
ZERO ON THAT BILL AND NOW. IS
THE OPPORTUNITY FOR ADD ONS
PLEASE GO AHEAD COMMITTEE
SECRETARY. CONSENT CALENDAR
FIRST PLEASE. CONSENT I
CALENDAR ITEM NUMBER. ONE FOUR
FIVE SIX SEVEN EIGHT NINE TEN
AND TWELVE. BERMAN BERMAN I. AS
I THANKS MAYES I'M SORRY BERMAN
I AND WOOD WOOD HI. FILE ITEM
NUMBER TWO AB THREE THREE FOUR.
MAYES MAYES AYE BERMAN BERMAN I
WOULD WOULD I. THAT'S RIGHT
FILE ITEM NUMBER THREE AB ONE
TEN MAYES MAYES AYE BERMAN
BERMAN I WOULD. HI JIM YEAH. DO
HEARING HE WAS AN- ALL RIGHT
THANK. ALL RIGHT THIS HEARING
IS ADJOURNED.
INSURANCE COMMITTEE CONSENT
CALENDAR ON APRIL TWENTY NINE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. I REMEMBER
ONE EIGHTY NINE EIGHTY. ITEM
NUMBER FOUR EIGHTY FOUR HUNDRED
ITEM NUMBER FIVE AB ELEVEN
FIFTY EIGHT. ITEM NUMBER. SIX
EIGHTY FOURTEEN SIXTY FIVE.
ADAM SEVEN EIGHTY FIFTY SIX
ITEM NUMBER EIGHT AB FOUR FOUR
ITEM NUMBER NINE AB TWELVE. I
REMEMBER TEN EIGHTY FOUR OH TWO
ITEM NUMBER TWELVE. EIGHTY
FIFTEEN ELEVEN. THIS HEARING IS
ADJOURNED.